[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and we're about to have a whale of a
time with everyone's favorite sex pest
the deep
this video is going to be filled to the
gills with everything that you need to
know about the character
and throughout it we'll be going over
his power set his full arc throughout
the show
and the characters comic book
differences there will be some spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out up to episode 7 of season 2
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and please smash that thumbs up button
if you enjoy the video
now before we get into the breakdown
though i just want to let you know that
this video is sponsored by fresca
the great tasting citrus drink that will
make you sign over your entire life to
the church of the collective
the link's gonna be in the description
and get 50 off your first order with the
code
balls deep make sure you do it now to
get a free wife with every drink
and turn your life around in more ways
than one
yay okay so the deep is pretty much the
boy's version of aquaman
captain obvious here giving you the
facts but in order to talk about his
power set
we first have to acknowledge that the
pair share a lot of similarities
primarily he possesses all of the
enhanced abilities that come with being
a child
injected with compound v and along with
his superhuman strength
the character is also super durable this
means that he can lift more than most
humans
and also withstand a lot more damage
without feeling any pain
because of this the character is able to
survive not only hitting water from
great heights
but also the pressures that come with
traversing the ocean floor
in the second season the deep mentions
swimming in the mariana trench
which has an atmospheric pressure that
is one thousand times
of what one would experience at sea
level this means that his body is
completely hot into the elements
and it would take an extreme amount of
force to damage him
however he does have a weak point and
that is his hideous
hideous gills you disgust me
now we've seen that when something is
placed inside of them that this causes
him immense physical pain
and if anyone ever decided to take him
down this would likely be how they'd go
about it
now because of the aforementioned guilds
the deep is able to breathe underwater
and swim at super speeds that far
outmatch mortal men
on top of this he's also able to
telepathically communicate with all
forms of sea life
and in his head he can have complete
conversations with them
the character developed this ability at
nine years old and since then he's
formed friendships with fish at the
beach
barbecues and aquariums do they barbecue
fish
i don't know it just sounded good now
this means that he can command them
and in season two we learn that he
actually had some halibut
investigate the wreckage of the plane
from the first season in the comic he
was actually involved in this crash
and during the scene we saw that the
character could fly though
that doesn't seem like it's been brought
across now the deep in the show differs
highly from the comics
and in the first season though we see
him sexually assault starlight
in the original work he wasn't present
when this happened
instead a train homeland and black noir
were the ones behind it
but they obviously decided to use the
character to show the fall of one of the
seven
the comic version is also african and he
never removes his helmet as he says it's
held in place because of an atlantean
curse
in the source material he's actually uh
not that bad of a guy
and compared to the rest of the seven
he's a complete angel
throughout the original work he doesn't
really get involved in any of the
sadistic things that the other members
of the seven do
and by the end of it he comes out as one
of the only survivors alongside
starlight
in the graphic novel he's more about
money and just maintaining his image
in all honesty he doesn't get that much
to do in the comics
and he's often seen complaining about
how he's relegated to just stand in the
background
whilst other members of the group get
their time in the spotlight
after the events of the comics he
actually joins a group known as the true
and that's really the last that we see
of him now as for the show
he's far more expanded upon and we
learned that like
most of the other members of the seven
his mother was injected with copious
amounts of compound b
when he was still in the womb when he
was growing up he started to discover
his powers
namely his ability to talk to fish and
though he thought he was going crazy
his mother told him that he was just
born that way unfortunately for the
character
he became severely self-conscious over
his guilds and this put him off from
ever letting anyone in thus he was
unable to form meaningful relationships
and whilst he quickly rose to the ranks
as a teen heartthrob
he became more and more dead inside
is that the right phrase i don't know
look either way
because of his popularity with women he
started to view them as disposable
objects
that he could use and abuse and this led
to him exposing himself to starlight in
order to blackmail her into giving him
oral
in the first season the deep taunts are
about this but starlight ends up in turn
almost
exposing him to the world at the believe
expo
the public joined the dots and realized
that it was the deep behind this
and thus vort decide to act worried
about the stock drops
they force him to apologize and then
send him on a sabbatical
out in sandusky though ward initially
promised that he might be able to return
one day
he discovers that this was just a lie
and they want him to remain
out of the spotlight and stay as a small
town hero
this pretty much sets up his arc for
both the seasons and we watch as he does
whatever he can to find redemption
in season 2 he's arrested once more for
exposing himself
and after being bailed out of jail by
eagle yorcha he joins
the church of the collective a
scientology parody
under the guidance of carol he's
promised the opportunity of rejoining
the seven
as long as he sticks to the rules and
keeps drinking
cool and delicious fresca carroll is
pretty much someone tasked with
rebuilding the image of fallen soups
and through the church after they're
accepted back into vote
they get a cut of the profits carol
finds him a wife called cassandra
and they give the guy an apology to her
that wins favour back with the public
once more
when queen maeve wants to enact her exit
strategy she goes to him for help
and promises him more positive publicity
in exchange for finding the wreckage of
flight 37
after he comes across footage of the
incident he hands it over to her
and then recruits a train to the church
of the collective
i actually got to see episode 8 early
thanks to amazon
and now i'm not going to spoil anything
let's just say
it's going to be interesting to see
where things go down the line
spoiler free reviews for the finale are
allowed at this point i think
so i can say that he has one of the
funniest lines in the entire season
and yeah you're gonna love it even if he
didn't
now if you're watching this in the
future and i've already seen the episode
then
you know yourself so let me know where
you think things are gonna go with him
as for the character in general i have
to say he's one of the most
unintentionally funny in the whole
series
i think it takes a great actor to pull
off a complete subplot that doesn't
really feel all that connected to the
main run
and chance crawford does a great job of
portraying someone coming to terms with
the fact
that they did something reprehensible
the deep is a really interesting
character
and it's going to be interesting to see
where things go from here on out
i would absolutely love to see him grow
long hair and a beard
just to start a riff on the dceu version
for the show
he's primarily based around the comic
book counterpart
but give the guy a hook for a hand or
something please
it'd be amazing now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the character
and what you think will happen down the
line if you enjoy this
video and want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our full
breakdown on the theory that black noir
is closer to stan edgar than you might
actually think we're also gonna be doing
full character breakdowns on the seven
so keep your eyes out for all of our
coverage don't forget we're also giving
away three copies of the marvel phase
one box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat with us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]